And this video will describe the trick
that's a very useful and very general for
improving any object recognition,
trainable system like a
convolutional neural network,
which we will refer to
as data set expansion.
Okay.
So we've seen that in a
commercial neural network. Uh,
we get some invariances done
are essentially built in,
uh, it's invariant to small
translations thanks to uh,
the convolution and the Max
pooling with sub sampling.
It's also a invariant to
small immunation changes.
If we introduce some contrast
normalization. However,
it's not built in us to be invariant with
respect to other things like rotations
or changes in scale. Uh,
and you'd imagine for say,
an object recognition application
because the object doesn't silly change.
If we zoom in or zoom out in the image
or if we rotate it a little bit, uh,
we would like to build in or to encourage
that type of invariance in our, uh,
in our conventional neural
network does actually. Uh,
but it turns out that
these, uh, variations,
I actually very easy to
generate artificially. Uh,
it's very easy to just take an image and
rotate it somewhat or change the scale
at which, uh, we're looking
at this a given image.
So very easy trick for improving the
performance of a computer vision system is
to actually generate this artificial
data and put it into our training set.
So expand the training set
using these transformation, uh,
to guide us into how we could
generate additional examples.
And so by doing this, by generating
this additional training data,
the neural network,
well,
instead learn to be in Varian to
these transformations because they're
explicitly there and the training set,
they will get explicitly the
signal that it should perform odd,
put the same object,
uh,
for any variation in the rotation
or scaling that will generate.
Sorry, is there a cartoon illustration
of how we could generate these additional
example?
So I'm now in each case
will essentially take a,
a smaller portion of the image and we'll
apply a transformation to it to get a,
an undoing, the transformation to get
an image in the same reference frame.
So, uh, for the original image,
we just take some crop at the center
and that would become a new training
example. Then if we want to
be invited to translation,
we could take the crop of the original
image and instead translate somewhat.
Uh, and then we would take that subset of
the image and this would become our new
image. Uh, we could, if we want to be
invariant with respect to rotations,
we could take the crop,
the original crop a window and just
rotate it randomly and then we would,
uh,
consider only the pixels in that window
and we would rotate and do the rotation
to get again as a rectangular
image, like a, the original image.
Uh, and similarly for scaling, uh,
we could just take the cropping window
and it stayed instead change its size.
So if we made it smaller than we could
crop fewer pixels and then we could undo
the scrubbing by scaling back to the
same size as the original image here,
in which case we'd get
easy zooming operations.
So we'd be changing the
scale of the actual image.
So for performing these operations,
I won't go into the detail.
You need to do some sort of interpolation
of pixels when you're doing these real
valued rotations or scaling a,
but often if you have
some software that does,
that allows you to manipulate images,
uh,
you can do a many of these
operations there. They often, uh, uh,
support it.
Yeah.
And other type of additional
examples we can generate, uh, to,
uh, improve the digitalization
performance of uh, uh,
computer vision system is to add so-called
elastic the formations of the image.
This is particularly useful
for character recognition.
So the idea is that we want to take
some original image and sort of locally
distorted a little bit such that it
still looks like the same kind of object,
but it's somewhat a little bit different.
It has a slightly different appearance,
but that's still, um, qualifies as
an appearance for that same object.
So one way of doing this is to first
generate a random distortion field.
So the distortion field,
which we see here would be for each Pixel,
a vector that tells us how the value of
that pixel should be displaced into the,
into dimensions. And so if
we generate the random, uh,
distortion field like this a while,
you get a bunch of arrows
pointing in random directions.
So they're generated here, each, uh,
using some Gaussian where each simple.
So each factor is, is
generated independently. So
we are generating each point,
which is a factor as the two dimensional
from a two dimensional Goshen and I,
if we applied that distortion field
to the image here, for instance,
we'd get something that's
actually a bit noisy. It's,
it's not a very convincing six,
uh,
and it just looks like
we've just added some noise.
However, if we take that random
field, we actually smooth it, uh,
using some,
uh,
smoothing kernel and doing a
correlation or convolution such as say,
a Gaussian kernel for instance. Uh,
then we can just smooth this, uh,
original random distortion field
to get a smoother transformation.
And if we apply this distortion
field that's been smooth,
then we actually get something like here,
the six has been into
this sort of deformation,
which still qualifies as a sixth to
pretty convincing a image of a six.
And so by generating many
of these distortions,
so we get another one where we
generated the random a distortion and,
and smooth the distortion.
We get a new six here,
which is actually quite
different from the previous one,
and it's still a very convincing
six. So a, we see that, uh,
this is another kind of operation,
uh,
which allows us to generate for
free additional training data.
So we would just add this as are in our
training set and label it as six. Again,
you need to be careful with, uh, uh,
in order to do some interpretation
of the pixels because this is, again,
a transformation which is continuous.
So it's not,
each vector does not displace the pixel
in the cell exactly on the original
grid. And so you have to do some,
uh, uh, a spatial interpolation.
Um, but again, this is the kind of thing
that's often supported and, and, uh, uh,
softwares that allow you to manipulate
the images to get more details about all
of this, I encourage you to, uh, uh,
look at this smart out paper that is
referenced on the website for discourse.
And, uh, just, uh, remember that, uh,
these elastic deformations or
any of the other kind of, uh, uh,
transformations we can,
uh,
use to expand the Dataset is not
actually just useful for neural networks,
but really any system that is trainable,
right?
So that's it for a dataset expansion.